Luca komm mal her lass uns mal nach
unten von hier aus springen ich habe
nämlich was gefunden was soll ich
ausgeleuchtet ist
ja
wieso bist du denn schon wieder so weit
ey lass da
[Musik]
aber hier sind überall noch Türen ich
habe Türen eigentlich immer abgebaut wir
schreiben Leute dass wir hier noch nicht
waren wo bist du die Treppe hochgegangen
ja und dann also ich habe da irgendwo so
ein kumpelstone hingesetzt und
Bruchstein
nach oben geguckt und dann habe ich
gesehen da waren Gang da waren wir noch
gar nicht let's go und jetzt kommt mein
prank was heißt Silberfisch auf Englisch
Leute ganz schnell
so ich habe die Silberfische Musik wo
bist du ich sehe auf jeden Fall dein
Name
[Musik]
wo bist du
was
[Musik]
laberst du es kann ach so Silberfisch
meinst du ja
das ist das Ende Sandra
soll ich da mal reingucken was passiert
willst du mir deine ganzen Sachen geben
und einmal ins Ende reinspringen ich
sag's andere nicht dass wir da erst die
Perlen rein tun müssen die soll einfach
mal in die Lava springen und jetzt
reinspringen also wenn du dich traust
kannst du schon mal reinspringen und
schon mal schauen was da drin so abgeht
okay tschüss
[Musik]
natürlich warten bis ich die also die
die in der Bären da rein gemacht habe
das habe ich jetzt gecheckt ich gebe dir
jetzt einmal kurz zu mir und dann machen
wir das normal wenn ich fertig bin okay
also
man muss nämlich überall welche rein
machen
aber wir haben dann doch nicht mehr
genug und das hier freilassen und wenn
ich jetzt nämlich den Block nach oben
setze
jetzt kannst du Portal springen
ja danke für nichts
[Musik]
sofort telefonieren
noch mal
[Musik]
soll ich das letzte Auge reinsetzen
definitiv genug Sandra schau dir das an
schau dir das Portal an okay ich mache
das Auge rein okay
okay
Leute ein paar Sekunden
vergessen ich hätte Blöcke mitnehmen
müssen also nochmal gesagt unser Plan
ist wenn wir jetzt oben sind nach Hause
laufen vorbereiten und vielleicht hast
aber danke für deine Hilfe das sieht
richtig schön aus finde ich sowas das
könnte man könnte mein Desktop
Hintergrund sein wenn das so mein
Desktop Hintergrund sein könnte und dann
dementsprechend wie spät es wäre wäre
das dann zu tun
verpiss Dich Leute ich werde mich
übrigens in Enderdrachen verwandeln
ich mache mir in die Hosen
die ganze Zeit drücke und wenn ich mich
in den in den Gamemode creative setze
dann Riesenberg dann ist das Problem das
andere das sieht wisst was ich mache das
Weg mit enderdrache
ich nehme was anderes Leute ich setze
mich jetzt nicht in creative mit dem
Enderdrachen weil das würde Sandra sehen
mit creative wird im Chat sehen Laser
luca hat sich in creative Modus gesetzt
deswegen ähm das machen wir dann nachher
irgendwann wenn sie mal kurz zum Server
irgendwie runter geht oder so
[Musik]
relativ dunkel
nicht im Bett
[Musik]
Laser
was geh jetzt schlafen danke für nichts
Mörder und ich bin weg
wenn du jetzt nicht schlafen gehst ich
schwöre dir ich dich ne ich
verstehe nicht wo mein Bett ist wo haben
wir das denn wo war ich denn das letzte
mal schlafen
nice wir konnten die Zeit nutzen ich bin
in den game of creative gegangen ich
habe zwar gecheatet ich habe zwar
gecheatet dadurch gerade aber jetzt war
kann ich mich jetzt änder dran
verkleiden dieses Tag ich habe
geschlafen kannst du da drauf
ja die Sache ist dadurch dass du jetzt
auch am Ende warst können halt andere
Monster kommen
[Musik]
so ich verstehe nicht mit nur so scheiße
kann ich bei dir sein
[Musik]
das war so dumm das hat aber auch nur
geklappt weil du vom Server
runtergegangen bist und ich dann in
Gamemode creative gehen konnte du
kleiner Hund meine Frage ist es
einfacher mit creative dann ähm
zu gewinnen gegen Ende Mann
creative ja die wird wahrscheinlich
trotzdem schreiben okay
[Musik]
nee
wie konnte das denn jetzt passieren
wir immer solche Sachen und immer immer
in diesem Bereich
so und unsere ganzen Bilder hey diese
scheiß Creeper es ist sehr helligste Tag
der kommt explodiert einfach rein damit
komplett aus Leute es ist soweit wir
fahren ans Ende kommt ihr klar ich bin
sehr sehr gespannt ob wir das hinkriegen
das Handy als allererstes bevor wir
reingehen Betten hier hin und einmal
Rechtsklick machen auf dein Bett ja was
steht im Chat wieder einstieg Punkt
gesetzt sehr gut
ins Ende
ich war noch gar nicht drin
[Musik]